The best thing I ever read, I saw on the Web.
And quite concisely, it said, "Being happy is better than not being happy.",...
...which is a criminally simplistic composition of thoughts that should be painfully obvious.
Of course, it's not that easy.
How do we even achieve this abstract idea of happiness?
And the key is a simple smile.
See, when you flash those pearly whites...
...your brain reacts the exact same way it would if you took cocaine.
And the endorphins addict you to happiness and your heart beats slower...
...and the cortisol that makes you stressed slips away like a dress on prom night,...
...showing nothing but those pearly white teeth with the message, "Hey, I won't bite."
You could put seven years on your life...
...and you don't have to adhere to some crazy diet; just give in to the addiction.
But unlike most fixations, your dependency is contagious...
...like a USB to a PC with 3 GBs powering it out.
Each smile makes another mouth widen...
...and another frown turns upside down.
Hell, I bet you're smiling now.